good evening the family of missing
two-year-old amari nicholson says they
are desperate for
any answers thanks for joining us here
at five i'm denise valdez good evening
i'm brian loftis we have team coverage
on the search for amari
joe moeller is with crews searching the
area he was last seen in but first
we go to the i-team's vanessa murphy
live in studio who just talked with the
child's maternal grandmother
who is in colorado it's an interview you
are seeing here first on channel eight
brian carrie howard says amari's mom
taylor nicholson who's her daughter
landed in colorado to help her recover
from surgery on april 30.
she tells me they facetimed with amari
that night
and he seemed happy but that's the last
time she says she saw her grandson
she says in the following days she did
not see her daughter face time with
amari again
then her daughter said she received a
call that he was kidnapped
and she rushed back to las vegas she
also says
she believes her daughter and her
boyfriend's story
isn't adding up you're not thinking that
your boyfriend who just
gave your son away to a stranger
like you you're not finding anything
wrong with that i'm terrified over here
i'm freaking mess i can't sleep i can't
eat i can't heal
she also tells me amari was also
supposed to visit her in colorado and
she purchased a plane ticket for him
but her daughter decided to leave him in
las vegas with her boyfriend
instead i called amari's mother taylor
nicholson today
we briefly talked and when i asked her
more about her boyfriend's story
it appears she hung up back to you